欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们 这一节课我们来讲一下关于三月新贸节和九月产购节的整体规划布局
这个每年都会有一个新贸节和产购节
它是按月来做活动的 这是平台的大活动
那么这两个活动期间都会有大量的流量
但是呢并不代表着每个商家都能够符合条件去参加报名
同时呢也并不代表着参加的这个活动
就一定能够获得很大的流量增长
这是很多人人家的误区
因为你想要获得流量
必须是通过报名成功之后
你有更好的产品
或者是说你店铺有更好的数据
才能够真正获得流量
如果你报名了
但是你店铺本身的数据或者是产品的数据都非常差
你报名的产品数据本来也很差
这种情况下是很难获得流量的
所以我们一定要知道他的规则和原理之后
再去报名活动
同时去选什么样的产品去报名
以及如何去打造这些已经报名的产品来进入各种会场获取更多的流量
那么大活动布局一个是有行业的
第二个就是有各个的会场
第三个就是有核心的会场以及其他的一些会场
比如说你看如果你报名了
那么就有这些组会场
组会场是一定要报名的
也就是每个店铺都要报名的
那么核心会场里面又有这几个会场
你看这几个会场并不是年年都一样的
它是会根据每年平台主推的方向
或者是说我们现在一个市场趋势去诞生的这些新的会场
这些会场每年都是不一样
一定要记住
并不是都一样
而且它的一个规则也不一样
当我们看到平台发布这些会场的时候
我们一定要去了解这些会场
它所需要的报名条件是什么
它获得排名的规则是什么
你一定要去知道一个就是报名条件
第二个就是排名的条件
这两个一定一定要去了解
同时呢
它是不同行业有不同的会场
同时不同的行业也有可能是不同的规则
排序规则或者是圈品的条件
所以你一定要根据你自己的行业去看对应的文档
然后把核心的一个规则跟报名条件理解
掌握
再针对你店铺的产品去报名跟去积累数据就可以了
不是每个行业都一样的
所以一定要是针对自己行业去做的
其他的会场这些会场也是会变的
每年都不一样
那么这个会场也是一样的
你要根据前面我们所说的报名的条件
以及它排序的规则这些去
你看这些有行业非常多
这些都让我们自己去了解这些条件跟一些排序的规则
那么接下来我们就要去把平台发布的一个PPT去研究
根据你的行业去研究
把核心的规则店铺能做的事情一定要把它列出来
列在表格里面
因为我们做事情如果不把它们列出来
就很容易遗漏或者是过一段时间
就不知道我们要去做什么事情了
所以先把事情裸列出来
然后根据他所提供的时间节点
去一件件的落地执行就可以了
那么我们整个三月经贸前和九月产购前就非常的有节奏了
另外这些就是我们所说的
它的一个会场
以及它的一个展示的逻辑
也就是说这里报名的会场
这边就是它排名的一些规则
你一定要去根据这些规则去理解
去思考当前我们的产品
需要怎么做才能够获得这些排名
同时你要重点关注的是什么呢
关注的是你已经报名的产品的整体的综合的数据效果
一定要集中资源去打造那些已经报名的产品
不然的话到时候活动一开始你报名的那些产品本身数据就很差
这种是很难很难获得流量的
你就会感觉到好像报名了都没有流量
甚至会更差
这就是因为你报名的产品没有数据
同时同行非常多的好产品
进入了这些榜单把你们的产品都排挤在外面了
那么你的产品都不如平时的获取流量的能力强
所以说就会导致你整个店铺的肿流量一定是下降的
所以这个一定要重视起来
第二个也是一样
我们要去找根据这些什么入口啊
去找到这些什么具体的会场啊
它的什么规则全部全部都弄清楚
最好你把它写出来再去执行
那么你整体的效果就会更加好
讲了那么多
那么我们来总结一下
这一整章节我们主要讲了哪些维度
我们去分析一下我们所学的这一章节
有哪些我们是没有记住的
或者是说我们比较难理解和没有把握的这些板块
我们可以重新的去再学一次
结合我们店铺的后台的实际操作去提升就可以了
我们单纯的去学习
不去操作的话是很难记住这些知识
也很难把这些知识变成技能的
所以一定要去多多的时间
多多的操作
把不懂得写下来再去操作
再去总结一下自己
从这些学习和这些操作中
能获得哪些新的思路
新的方法都可以写一下
总结一下
慢慢形成了你自己的一个整体的一个运营框架
运营思路
以及能够产生一些更加符合你们店铺运营的一个新的方法
所以我们一定要多去实践
好了
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见